[Music]
hey
you guys here we are once again it's
wednesday right
yeah it's wednesday i told i said to the
guys here in the conversation down here
in the chat room i was watching this
sn95 i think it's sn95 starship
from [ __ ] spacex i was watching it
it's getting ready to launch
you guys [ __ ] it up had to come in
here and stream but i don't know when
it's going to launch there's no
countdown
it's just they're going through all the
pre-flight [ __ ] they're
they're going to tell you like about 30
seconds before it launches when they're
oh by the way
by the way we're going we you guys don't
need it now
yeah well they're making it up as they
go along
okay that's his spaceship mandy launches
it when it's [ __ ] ready
it'll go well whenever i push the button
that's what it goes
badass man it's [ __ ] it's like it
says like something other goddamn 1950s
it [ __ ] takes a
it could flip on its side and then come
right back and land right where it right
where it started that's what it's gonna
do
because i feel like a lot of 50s movies
had that what what was the one that i
was thinking of that was on mystery
science theater about the guy that
landed on the chicken nugget and then he
shrank
i don't know uh phantom planet okay and
i think it was phantom planet where they
had the
you know the the phallic looking rocket
and it goes up and then it's like whoop
back and onto the plane yeah
this thing's gonna almost flip on its
side and then land right back down it's
huge it's bigger than the [ __ ] saturn
rocket
it's huge i'm telling you it's [ __ ]
huge blowing my [ __ ] mind
i believe you and the
spacex is kicking [ __ ] ass man i'm
super impressed
they've run out of payloads they're
gonna don't you guys want to launch
anything
want to launch it anyone want to go into
space yeah
yeah we'll pay you to go into space how
about that it's cheap it's like almost
like a little bit more expensive than a
damn airplane flight
one of the starship ones is gonna you
can put like
30 satellites in it and let them all go
at once can i pay to launch someone else
into space
the one on the rock asking for a friend
one of the rock is going to be a
passenger rocket it carries second like
20 30 40 people or something like that
and it can be anywhere in the world like
in 15 minutes
that's pretty cool it's badass just
laying on i want to be able to pay to
send someone else into space and like
leave them there
because i'm a super villain easy to go
to space now
that's what i want he's gonna he's just
gonna land on the moon just for shits
and giggles and then come back
like he didn't even do it just because i
can't he's like and then i'm gonna run
naked across the moon
i'm on the moon [ __ ] all right take a
selfie let's see if everybody's here
yeah everybody's here let's see
said they were in florida where in
florida you at where are you at
probably far i mean florida's big it's
cold here it's cold here today
this morning well we woke up and i was
like
i think i woke up at 5 30 or 6 or
something
because you know old people he had
insomnia but uh
yeah so i woke up and i'm like wow it's
cold in here and i went out for a walk
at about seven
and it was 41 but it felt colder than
yesterday when
yesterday it also said it was 41. yeah
and then
a couple hours later that was like at
7am and then a couple hours
like at 9 or 10 i looked at my phone and
they said oh now it's 38.
so now it's like getting colder as the
sun came up which is
weird badger says that uh elon's going
to [ __ ]
launch the rocket when he gets done
finishing that joint yeah
that's what happens come on what happens
so what happens when you give a goth kid
a [ __ ] the ability to make [ __ ]
spaceships
yeah where's your spaceship i thought
you were gonna build one
i don't have the money i mean that dude
had paypal he's got a [ __ ] bank
you know what i mean he can make a
spaceship he's got a [ __ ] hot goth
girlfriend and everything man
we were we need to go hang
musk i'm getting [ __ ] old dude i want
to be the first
man to go to mars send me i'll [ __ ]
sleep the whole way
i could sleep the whole way oh i believe
that
yeah and i don't even care if it's a
one-way trip you can come with me
he'll just stay on call as cold as [ __ ]
well yeah
we'll be up there freezing our tits off
yeah there's nothing to do well yeah
what the hell we gonna do once we get up
there
they're gonna send a bunch of [ __ ] first
enough to make a whole city
that's what they're going to do okay and
then they send the people and they
assemble it well yeah because otherwise
people will be up there going
go what'd it do yeah it's not like it
was
i'll just take a bunch remember how we
used to fantasize about going to mars
back in the 50s
where you go there in the ship and
you're stuck you're like
just with what you bring yeah because
it's cost so much to launch something
now they'll just sit back for a [ __ ]
10 years and send [ __ ]
billions of metric tons of [ __ ]
material
you know why why bother sending people
you know what i mean
for four years you can just send
everything enough to make a whole
[ __ ]
two or three battleships and then some
guy and then you send robots
then the robots assemble it and then you
just send some dudes that are [ __ ]
like
rent renters send some renters they
don't even work
sitting up there [ __ ] on welfare
smoking dope on mars
conducting something sophie said we
could stream the show for more stream
the show for mars
will be the first podcast streaming live
they're just gonna be up there
hanging out he's gonna be up there
hanging out in a bar
doing business with three three tinted
[ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
running from koh hagan never ever uh
remember what was the name of that what
title regal
recall yeah yeah [ __ ]
nothing to do up there except [ __ ]
hang out in a bar
i could see that i mean because yeah
like i said it's probably all i'd end up
doing well it's the same [ __ ] i end up
doing down here hanging out bars and
drinking and
reading books and watching movies yeah
but that's what most people end up doing
what the hell else is there to do
not much then they tell you the [ __ ]
alien artifacts in the mountains
yeah we'll go look for alien arts yeah
all right so uh so let's talk about moby
yeah this is a documentary so
you know don't you can't say like too
much about it well okay
what my original plan was because i saw
that shutter
had added a new movie and usually i like
to watch the shutter ones and then i'll
review them so i watched it last night
and it's an okay movie but it wasn't
really a horror movie
and i was like well there's not really
much to talk about
if you want to check it out if you have
shutter
one thing i'm gonna say it's called
zombie child
it's french and if you're really into
french movies and like arty movies
and real slow type stuff then
you should watch it otherwise don't
watch it because it's not
a horror movie but it's like a cool
concept like i like the concept that
they're doing
they're telling the story of clairvius
narcisse who if you don't know that is
was the guy that was buried he was
he's kind of the one that um brought the
whole haitian zombie thing like to the
west not the west but like to the united
states because of wade davis and
serpent the rainbow and all that kind of
stuff um so it's kind of about him but
it's also about
it has like a fictional element of a
girl that
is a relative of his and she's at a
boarding school in france and it kind of
goes back and forth between the two
things
like i said it's it was an okay movie
but it's very very very
arty and very very very i checked
ponderous this is
french as [ __ ] it was french as [ __ ]
only the french
could make a movie about a bunch of
lesbian schoolgirl girls in a boarding
school and it'd end up being boring
they talked their way through the whole
[ __ ] thing
okay well where's this [ __ ] gonna
[ __ ] throw down it never did
yeah like i said it's you know i'm not
[ __ ] on the movie but it's
it's not a horror movie it's it's a
drama had me tell this story that should
be triple x
it's a drama yeah it should be triple x
have me tell a story
well you know which is it which is a
good segue
into talking about the movie that we're
actually talking which we actually saw
like it was probably a few days ago yeah
this one was a lot better it was
this was on hulu but i think it's on
amazon prime as well
yeah this is called skin history of
nudity in the movies because of course
when i'm i'm scrolling through the stuff
on hulu and i'm like naked people all
right i'm on board with that
the history of nude scenes in hollywood
movies going on this was a fascinating
that's really interesting
it goes all the way back to the to the
20s yeah it goes
all the way back to the 20s the start of
film
really you know a lot of the [ __ ] that
was going on in the 20s that
real reminiscent to what was happening
in the
i wouldn't say 70s but 80s because 70s
was a little more wild than the 80s in a
lot of way
yeah 80s kind of toned down a lot of 20s
movies
you could play that in the 80s and
people would still enjoy it yeah
but there was semi-nudity it was a
little more corny and stagey
it looked like showgirls but you know
some people would get it get it get into
that
you know the horror of the 20s was
pretty was better
it was pretty good true borla boris
scarlot bella goes like the black cat
that was 30s 30s yeah that's true that
was
that was still before the haze code i
think though an interesting thing yeah
because they went into that obviously
because you know
they went into a lot of stuff about
censorship in the movies and everything
and they
you know talked to a lady from the mpaa
and they talked about the haze code
one thing that i wasn't real aware of is
that even though the haze code
passed and where whenever it passed 1934
whenever it was
um a lot of that doesn't necessarily
mean that
all the movies adhered to it and it
wasn't a big
like it was it didn't seem like it was
super enforced at first
like even after they passed it like some
movie makers were
still they just did the [ __ ] anyway and
it's
my favorite nothing much happened my
favorite old movie
that was wild was boris karloff belle
lugosi
the black cat it's not very long you
could probably see it for free on
youtube
um it's probably about an hour long huh
maybe
maybe i don't know if i remember yeah
movies were shorter but yeah
and man that thing's got all these
all this [ __ ] subject matter that
didn't fly later on in it
satanism uh human sacrifice
or something [ __ ] yeah i mean they
didn't show it but yeah almost showed
the shadow of it yeah um
scantily clad hot classy satanist chicks
uh kind of like weird stealing people's
daughters
uh event revenge high-tech [ __ ]
uh it was just it was [ __ ] wild flick
it was yeah it was really wild for the
day but it would have been really
unsettling for the day
it's also kind of hinted a bit at
necrophilia
yeah kind of had a bluebird beard thing
where guy was satanist
guy was he was real rich he built a damn
super futuristic mansion on top
of a of the world war one battle ground
where he on purpose sacrificed his own
unit that he commanded back in the army
he sacrificed him as a human sacrifice
to consecrate the ground with evil
energy
like you do yeah and then he built his
second temple on there and then he stole
he he had us a bunch of
women that i guess he killed him in
their primer they died he claimed they
died but then he
he had him preserved in glass caskets
and i think i kind of suspect he killed
him when they when he got tired of them
i guess and then he ended up with his
buddies
i guess underage daughter and he had her
kind of enslaved she didn't really know
though she's kind of walked around in a
stupor i guess
dressed in a real low cut kind of 30s
looking
gown it's like here i'll just give you
some roofies if you can walk around
naked like a whole bunch of ultra
wealthy
powerful people were coming over for
these satanic
rituals i guess it was like an orgy
and his he's [ __ ] praying to satan
and [ __ ] boris karl off this
that's a [ __ ] wild flick and then
yeah particularly for the time because
as i said i do feel like sometimes
people think that
you couldn't show any of this kind of
[ __ ] you could you could
in the yeah for a while you could and
honestly
even if you see like some us movies from
pre haze code they're pretty
you know you know not compared to [ __ ]
nowadays they're not gonna show [ __ ]
you know
hostile or anything like that but
for the time it's kind of shocking um
but the thing about it is that in europe
i feel like they were kind of
way more ahead of the curve particularly
when sex and nudity was concerned
because i do feel like they talked a
little bit about there was a movie
called
ecstasy i can't remember what year it
came out but hedy lamarr was in it
and i think that it was shot in god the
netherlands or somewhere
and she's just like running around naked
and there's they even showed her face
like having an orgasm which is like way
ahead of the curve
particularly for how long ago this movie
came out
and i feel like that even that wouldn't
have flown
in uh the u.s cuz i don't know why but
there's one weird thing about american
culture is that we're pretty much
fine with showing violence in movies up
to a point like if you're getting real
egregious with it like a torture point
or something like that then you might
run into problems
but any time you're showing nudity
particularly male nudity we seem to have
a lot more problems with like show and
dicks than they than tits i mean tits
they'll show tits all day long
um they don't like to show bush they
don't like to show
penises and they don't like to show
women
enjoying sex which is very like they
don't like to imply like women having
orgasms or anything like that it's just
it's it's really touching some weird
[ __ ] it seems very strange to me they
showed
some history they talked about the the
making of caligula that had old west's
name
and it wasn't malcolm mcdowell i think
was my favorite part he was in it he was
telling a bunch of stories
he's so he's awesome you had uh oh
british dude that scares the [ __ ] at me
when i was a kid
oliver reed there was i didn't know
about this you didn't know about that
wrestling scene
no i didn't know about that [ __ ] man oh
that's a famous famous scene there was
some movie where oliver read
it's women in love women based on the
d.h lawrence novel he gets naked with
some other dude in this uh
mansion down in his living room with the
in front of the fireplace and the bare
skin
rug and they have some greco-roman
wrestling
and uh then they evidently
wrestle each other into a stalemate but
reid
just thought that that's what the scene
was but then they re-edited that [ __ ]
behind his back to make it look like it
was gay
sex that happened well no what ended up
what he said i thought well what ended
up happening
was that this scene if you've seen women
in [ __ ]
which i have um that's because i
i think i read the book as well like
many years ago but there's this very
famous scene in the movie with oliver
reed and i can't remember the name of
the other actor yeah there's a younger
oliver reed yeah yeah yeah there's
like you know it wasn't like he wasn't
like a big big drunk
yeah i mean he was probably drunk yeah
she's not gonna lie
but yeah so so they're like wrestling in
front of the fireplace
and the funniest thing about this was
that they
basically the the sensors or whatever
said you can't have that scene of the
two guys wrestling like that it goes on
too long or it's too gay
but then they cut it down and when they
cut it down it looked even more gay
because it's like then it didn't look
like they were wrestling it looked like
they'd been [ __ ] and then they were
laying there going all spins and
everything
now oliver reed he had a bad habit for
getting arrested here in the united
states
alan bates thank you that was the other
actor's name yeah he alvarez
he um had a habit of getting naked and
getting arrested here in the united
states he
did yeah he got drunk [ __ ] took his
clothes off and was walking down
this thing that was somewhere in
hollywood wouldn't it i can't remember
but yeah
somewhere in the suburbs you know where
where the [ __ ] movie stars live and
these
cops got him every no he took us he took
his clothes off at a bar i think
and the cops got him like you do they
let him go
you know he was [ __ ] oliver reed and
then he was like yeah he's
he does those things and then like the
very next day i think he had to do the
merv griffin show
and they mentioned it and [ __ ] he just
kind of laughed it off he's like yeah
yeah i'm oliver reed what are you gonna
do you know what i mean yeah
he was in it was just england
re-invading the united states
but you know he's like i'm going to
swing my dick all over this one
it's understandable though you know
[ __ ] hollywood was a really bad
influence on any kind of foreign
actor they came here
they don't think they were used to that
level of [ __ ] partying and that level
of
attention and that level of celebrity
yeah i mean because the british i mean
they have the same type of celebrity
culture over there but it's not as big
it's not as big yeah not as
cash fueled and cocaine-fueled as it was
back then
yeah it's not quite to the same yeah and
the magnitude yeah i suppose
well i heard you know even guys like tom
baker you know they'd get done shooting
[ __ ]
doctor who and just go to local pub and
hang out
yeah at the local pub you couldn't do
that united states no
no you couldn't go look those they they
can't go out in public at least not back
in those days
nowadays nobody gives a [ __ ] you could
be well and it depends where you live
too because um one of the reasons why a
lot of real famous people live in new
york city is because you can generally
walk down the street and no one will
bother you
and i've seen famous people just walking
around in new york city
as well and no one bothers them
everybody knows who they are
like so even people even know where they
live yeah but because they
like just walk down and get bagels or
whatever but it's like they just don't
get bothered there because new yorkers
just like meh whatever
right now you'd probably get robbed i
heard i heard new york's really bad
right now
yeah well i don't know i've been there a
long time but um but yeah so oh
you were talking about malcolm mcdowell
he was talking about because they went a
lot into caligula obviously because that
was kind of a big thing
and the funniest thing about that i
don't know if this is true or not dr
mcdowell says
he's like well basically everybody else
was naked in caligula
and he'd been naked in a bunch of other
movies obviously he was an if he was in
clockwork orange and uh he was naked in
that too had somebody looking up his
butt with a flashlight you know
so he said well i feel like
if i'm caligula that everybody else is
naked and i'm not
because it's like a power trip type
thing so he's like when i keep my
clothes on in this because everyone else
is naked
but he says and i said i don't know if
this is true or not but he said that he
didn't know that this was gonna be
like a straight-up porn movie because it
essentially is a porn
yeah um he said he didn't really know
that he's like because
he's like what they would do is they
would they would have footage of me just
like looking
wistfully over there like looking with
satisfaction or smuggly or
over there or whatever and then it's
like and then they'd edit it so there
was like this big [ __ ] orgy with all
these naked people like [ __ ] he's
like i wasn't really looking at that
like when they shot it but when they
edit it back he's like so i went to go
see the movie and i'm like what the [ __ ]
i remember i remember seeing that movie
a long time ago and
really i didn't walk away from it
thinking that it was that pornographic
it was x-rated
but x-rated didn't mean triple x it was
very different
it's kind of like a real hard nc 17.
yeah they went a lot into but not it
would
not triple x here's something that i
didn't really or maybe i did know this
and i forgot about it but basically the
x rating it wasn't like
an official thing it just means it
couldn't rate it it wasn't rated
yeah so they're like well yeah they said
that's why porn movies
and any movie you could slap an x on it
yeah it didn't have to be
unrated it didn't have to go through uh
the mpaa or whatever to get that rating
you could just
put it on an x but they're like that's
why porn movies started saying they were
triple x now because x started to like
lose all the meaning
yeah particularly after midnight cowboy
won an oscar because that was rated
you see that today and it's not a big
deal at all yeah it's like oh a male
gigolo we can't have that
and i think like i said there was some
male nudity in it and it was really
weird they talked to amy heckerling who
directed uh fast times at richmond high
and she that would have been x back then
probably but she thought it was very
funny that they didn't have
a problem obviously showing female
nudity
jennifer jason lee was naked in it and
uh you know and um
phoebe cates was naked in it they're
like but during this
awkward sex scene between jennifer jason
lee and that other actor they're like
they they initially shot it where he was
naked or you could kind of see part of
it and they're like oh no
we can show we can show the women naked
but not him there was some [ __ ] in there
in the 70s they would have given me the
next rating remember but she walked in
on him on the in the bathroom i was
jerking out they probably gave him a
judge
but they showed him but they didn't show
you knew what he was doing but they
didn't it wasn't graphic but i think
they
yeah because phoebe case expression like
when she walks and she's like
and there was like some nudity and then
there was some sex scenes back in the
60s or 70s that would have been an
x-rated
i like that i think a lot of people
still relate to that movie because
she wanted to show today because amy
heckerling wanted to show that what
what young sex was really like like is
really awkward and stilted and
everything is like it wasn't like they
usually showed in the movies
she's like that's why i liked that scene
with phoebe kate's like popping her top
off with her tits popping out
and then a couple minutes later she
walks in on judge reinhold jerking off
in the bathroom because she's like just
to show the difference between like the
reality and the fantasy or whatever
um so yeah they they really did go a lot
into like i said the rating system
they had uh they talked about marilyn
monroe and how
her how previous to that her being in
playboy
it was kind of like if you showed up
naked in a movie or something was really
scandalous
and but that you know her doing that in
playboy and it didn't mess up her career
or anything that was kind of like open
the floodgates they talked to
mamie van doren who i had seen some
movies with her in it because
she was in a couple movies that were on
mystery science theater like girls town
and stuff
and i knew that she'd done some nude
scenes but they showed
one movie that she was in and i couldn't
remember what it was and i was like holy
crap
it was she i mean she's naked and she's
rolling around on the bed going hey
blah blah and i was like holy crap i
didn't know it was that nude of a scene
but yeah there you go
mango's talking about how awesome oliver
reed was in the brood that yeah
yeah that's really where i think that
was the first movie i ever saw with him
in it when i was a kid
yeah and that character [ __ ] scared
me i was like whoa
yeah he's a scary person yeah
and then i saw i also saw uh
burnt offerings yeah but i think i saw
that after
after i saw the brood but you know
oliver reed
oliver reed intimidated me when i was a
little kid like i said before you
him and and [ __ ] michael caine michael
caine
it's like they were going to hit you you
know what i mean well they might yeah
like they're going to [ __ ] hit you at
any moment
[Laughter]
slap the [ __ ] out of you it's like i'm
not
going to slap the [ __ ] out of me looking
it's just
i can see that they they do definitely
have that uh intimidating gonna gonna
smack you
yeah energy going on the first time i
ever saw michael kane kind of make play
a good guy was in the island
yeah and i was still kind of spooked
about him when i was watching the island
back when you kept suspecting that he
was going to turn
out to be interviewing the villain
[Laughter]
because my impression of him came from
the hand
yeah he was a good guy in jaws 4 i think
wouldn't it i don't know it's been a
long time since i think i saw that [ __ ]
in the movie he played an assassin in
some
british movie he was on a lot of british
yeah
he was playing some assassin uh they
said
they said that that was a pretty well
known role for him when he was in the
well he was in
what was that movie called alfie
didn't they remake it with jude law
somebody help me i don't know
i don't have it but this was a good
movie though you know just to tell you
the history of american film uh
it's really really good but the thing
about it though and
i think they balanced this really well
and it's pretty long it's pretty
comprehensive i think it was like two
hours and 10 minutes or so but it didn't
seem like that long because it was like
really interesting and they got a lot of
a lot of guests a lot of people like to
talk about all the nude scenes they had
done and [ __ ] like that
but one of the things that i think they
did really well was they balanced
because they were talking about you know
censorship and different
mores and stuff and they kind of went
through the history but they're also
saying that
even though you know the 60s and the 70s
everything were much more permissive
one kind of downside to that is that
because it was so permissive you were
kind of expected to do it whether you
wanted to or not
and they're saying that really the whole
thing that people got
later on like in maybe starting in the
80s and 90s
where they would say in their contract
you know this is the nudity i will do
this is what you're allowed to do
they're like that was um kind of an
outgrowth of that just because
it was so permissive back in the 60s and
70s that it was just getting abused
you would just turn up on set and they'd
be like yeah we'll get naked or you're
fired
so um i think uh i think
the thing that tripped me out was
watching it was i didn't realize when
they started the code
back in the back in the 30s yeah it was
odd
the attitude of the of the people who
who wanted that code it was mostly a
catholic
thing i feel like it started out as like
a catholic watchdog type of group but
what was funny is that they
they treated the movie theater
as kind of like i guess public
open pub you know right like everybody
could just like everybody including
little kids could go in there
they were so they just they wanted to
control exactly what you saw but they
didn't
think of a damn rating system which
seems like the most obvious thing
the obvious thing they didn't really
start doing that until the 70s yeah
they went through the trouble really the
trouble
of trying to control the entire industry
at once saying that you can't and they
had like a very specific list you can't
do this you can't
and it wasn't just nudity it was all
kind of stuff they didn't
they didn't for some reason they just
didn't think of well why don't we just
make it so some movies only adults can
go to them
right they didn't think of that uh we
have to defend the children we'll get
the [ __ ] children out of there yeah
it's like children shouldn't be watching
it
you think you'd think that you would
think that that would just be obvious
yeah because what ends up happening if
you do that is that every movie has to
be safe for kids
like you can't like just watch something
that kids aren't allowed to watch now
that's
stupid every movie is [ __ ] g-rated
yeah it's like
nobody wants that yeah nobody wants that
i don't know what made him
think like that well i don't know i do
feel like those kind of groups back then
they kind of had a thing where they
just felt like they had the moral high
ground so they could just like tell you
tell everybody else even if even people
that weren't catholics or didn't give a
[ __ ] or
it's just very somebody would have come
it's very strange
we gotta keep the kids out of certain
movies we'll put a rating on it yeah i
don't have a problem with that we'll
make
more money if on the r rated in the in
the pg rated
that way everybody can see what they
want to see and you can you know
you would think that that would be a
no-brainer yeah because i mean obviously
i don't think kids should be watching
porn or kids should be watching
really you know torture porn or like
really really violent horror movies
that's not what the audience the
audience wanted to see right semi-nudity
and they wanted to decide
adults want to see that then [ __ ] man
yeah it's [ __ ] ridiculous
and like i said as long as the people in
the movies are okay with it
yeah those ribs are gonna be out of the
oven in a minute oh yeah okay so we're
making ribs and some
potatoes that's gonna be early dinner
yeah well i guess
only dinner because i'm not gonna eat
again later it takes for three hours
um that sounds really good but yeah so
this is as i said a thing it's on hulu
and i think somebody else said it was am
on amazon prime as well it's really
really good i thought it was like really
fascinating and
even though i knew some of the stuff
there was a lot of new material in there
or like little factoids that i didn't
know
so yeah if you're into the history of
film or anything like that then i
definitely recommend
checking it out and i guess it's
wednesday so
we will see you guys again on our next
live stream which is going to be on
saturday and uh so have a good rest of
your day
everybody and we'll see you guys in a
couple of days
bye